دعني اسالك عن
الاستمرار منظمات من بينها الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل
ونقابه المحامين في الترويج لمبادره ترمي
الى اطلاق حوار وطني وهذا هدف يبدو انه
صعب المنال في ظل عدم تجاوب الرئيس معها
ما موقفكم من هذه المبادره
المبادره هذه هي اولا تعبر على فقط على
جزء من طموحات طموحات الشعبيه لانه اتحاد
العام التونسي الشغل وهيئه المحامين وربطه
التونسيه الدفاع حقوق الانسان وكذلك يعني
المنظمه يعني الحقوق الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه هي تمثل جزء من طموحات الشعب
التونسي فالتموحات الشعب التونسي تمثله
ايضا الاتحاد التونسي لصناعه والتجاره
والاتحاد الفلاحين الاتحاد التونسي للمراه
وجوزه كبير من المجتمع المدني هذا فضلا
على ان اللي كان لكي تكون مبادره يعني
منسجمه ومقبوله يجب ان تمثل يعني طموحات
الشعب التونسي بمختلف مكوناته وكذلك كرهات
الدوله التي تمثلها الحكومه لان يعني
الدوله التونسيه التزامات مع المؤسسات
الماليه الدوليه وكذلك التزامات ثنائيه
والتزامات اقليميه وبالتالي لكي تكون هناك
مبادره مقبوله يجب مع كل هذه الاطراف اما
يعني تقديم مبادره من طرف اربعه منظمات
يعني تمثل جزء من يعني مكونات المجتمع لا
يمكن ان ترتقي الى مبادره يعني جديه يمكن
اجتمع حول كافه الاطراف الفاعلين في
البلاد التونسيه ولذلك لماذا لا تاخذ هذه
المبادره ويتم ويتم تعزيزها واضافه اشياء
عليها او فتح خطوط اخرى مع الاخرين والبدء
في تطبيقه يعني لماذا
يبدو كانها مبادره مبادره ناقصه
اعلى موجودين في مجلس النواب ومستعدين
للحوار مع كل الاطراف التي تريد ذلك
وبالتالي يعني
هاته المنظمات ارادت فعلا تقديم عرض جدي
للحلول يعني تجمع كامل مكونات الشعب
التونسي فضلا على
الوظيفه التنفيذيه التي هي مسؤوليه مسؤوله
على سياسه الحكومه نحن مستعدون لذلك وما
عليهم الا ان يقدموا طلب في الغرض يعني
انتم عندكم تحفظات على هذه المبادره من
مواقفكم الخاصه بكم لكن البعض يرى بانه
بانها لانها تتماهى مع موقف الرئيس هل
يمكنكم في لحظه ما لاختلاف مع الرئيس ودعم
هذه المبادره
ما انا قلت لك يعني المبادره هذه هي
منقوصه ولا يمكن انا ان ترتقي الى حل يقبل
من طرف كل مكونات يعني
البلاد التونسيه سواء يعني طموحات المجتمع
او الكريات الدوله وبالتالي اقول وان كل
المبادرات وكل المقترحات مستعدين لقبولها
ودراستها بشرط يعني ان يعبر عن ذلك صراحه
لا اكثر ولا